ah yes the noble art of speed running
ladies and gentlemen
once hailed to be exclusive to mostly
gamers who are speed running video games
now the scammers are in on it guys we
got sec speed runs coming through and
i'm excited about it i for one think
it's gonna be a very
interesting new sport so if you if you'd
like to compete
no i'm just kidding don't you you don't
want to compete with this
uh but what we're talking about today is
this guy i've never seen an sec
indictment
so quick boys this thing right here
is about a twitter investor stock
account
which grew its following from a
relatively just like
13 000 followers and used it to shill
penny stocks in order to make a quick
buck
now i think three or four months from
when they started
ladies and gentlemen
government comes knocking baby and i
think it's an interesting sign
of the sec's new priorities as they see
um
the unregulated market on twitter of
people just shilling random stocks
we all know that a lot of it's illegal
but nobody's really been doing anything
about it it's been kind of
the wild west but this i think signifies
that if you're out there shilling stocks
shilling um companies
they're watching for sure i mean because
this is a small account the account is
called
oc millionaire bulls make money bearers
make money
pigs get slaughtered and wolves take
everything this is
also known as the vapid profile
something that sounds cool
but ultimately anybody who say pigs get
slaughtered
often time you're the guy getting
slaughtered it just takes a while like
you're the guy getting indicted by the
sec so who are you talking about
right this person also calls himself a
penny stock
wizard wow that's interesting now here's
the deal
uh our boy oc millionaire he was
shilling
and a cannabis company that uh was known
for
basically nothing i mean they're just
like this defunct company
and on december 10th he starts pumping
it up boys
and as you can see around that time
frame it of course
spikes about four thousand percent and
immediately it dumps
in that time he sold his stocks he
bought 41 million
shares of stock this is all these penny
stocks are he's like
you got 10 million shares for 10 dollars
i mean that's basically how it is
and he ended up making let's see here oh
almost a million dollars
which in a way is like i mean i'm
shocked that you can profit that much
off such a tiny audience that's like my
twitter audience i mean actually come to
think of it
it's giving me an idea no no no wait
wait not though because they have morals
but yeah he shield this to his followers
increased four thousand percent he
profited off of it and then the sec is
like
no you don't no actually
bunk them on the head and so yeah you
love to see it
and i think that i hope that this is the
start of
more um accountability with this stuff
because these people
he was just shilling arcs again and
again and again sorry that's the name of
the cannabis company if you guys don't
know
just shilling it man always talking
about
what's going on it's so great it's so
great this is what you call fraud i
think most people
aren't aware if you own a position you
shill it out especially if you're
telling people false information
buddy that's called fraud and lastly i
want to share a fun little meme with you
guys to end the day because i saw this
and it sums up my
channel in four seconds ladies and
gentlemen this is my channel
wake up and smell the coffee